all right it's trouble in Paradise for
Joe and Kamala a new book is dishing out
the dirt on how the president truly
feels about his number two and get this
the big guy found finds Kamala Harris to
be annoying yes no kidding so does half
the Country Joe telling friends the
Kamala was a quote work in progress in
his early days in the White House Biden
is also frustrated the kamala's husband
Doug had been complaining about her
policy portfolio which included the
Border crisis according to the book
quote Biden was annoyed he hadn't asked
Harris to do anything he hadn't done as
vice president and she begged him for
the voting rights assignment it's been a
rough go for kamalan numerous staffers
have run for the doors and she can't
stop making awkward moments like this
you need to get to go I need to be able
to get where you need to go to do the
work and get home when we talk about the
children of the community
they are a children of the community the
significance of the passage of time so
when you think about it there is great
significance to the passage of time
you're going to literally see the
craters on the moon with your own eyes
with your own eyes I'm telling you
oh my gosh all right Jesse should Biden
have expected more when he chose her
based on identity politics
anyone would have expected more I think
back to the previous relationships that
I've covered of presidents and vice
presidents you never heard about the
drama until like the eighth year or the
last year or even after they had left
off Gore only came out against Bill
Clinton when he lost and said the
Lewinsky thing might have cost me and
then Cheney got a little perturbed at w
about the scooter Libby thing at the way
end of that presidency right and then
and then and then Biden kind of sulked
when Barack Obama endorsed Hillary but
that didn't even really come out until
way later and then we all know what
happened with Pence and Trump what
happened I don't remember we don't need
to get into that but this happened right
away like first year second year there's
drama now a sexist would say but it's
because she's a woman but I don't say
that I say it's because she's Kamala
Harris
thank you just you're welcome very clear
all right Dana you know even the White
House admits that her Inner Circle is
not serving her well but shouldn't she
know better than to have an inner circle
that hates her in his constantly I don't
know if she has a choice right do you
remember when she dropped out of the
presidential race before there were any
votes and do you remember that was as
long I think they had 50 people on the
record who had worked for her saying how
terrible it had been so I think also as
a president if you're dealing with the
fact that she's in the news every day in
a negative way that's not what you
signed up for okay so I can understand
that I think the thing that really got
to me about this story is that the
second gentleman weighed in yeah I'm
like oh no no no sir I I think that you
should just say I'm very happy to be
here thank you so much I'm what would
you like me to do ribbon cutting
tomorrow I'm on top of it no problem and
he wants to advise her in private of
course you should do that but you cannot
complain on her behalf don't ever do
that I would be mortified I think any
strong woman would be mortified you know
Harold the fact is is that the White
House has been unable to describe what
she's been up to and now that we've had
this incredible number of of people
crossing the border 2.4 million and
that's her bailiwick I mean shouldn't
the White House be more involved and say
you know Kamala you get to it
you would you would think so look every
it's no secret these two either their
staffs or the two of them the president
the vice president have not quite found
their groove and they need to try to
find it sooner rather than later I think
President Biden has a unique perspective
as the article suggests because he was
and we all know he was the vice
president right and he was asked to do
things uh and frankly the job of the
vice president is to do the things the
president wants you to do and to do it
with competence enthusiasm and as much
political Savvy as you can I think the
jury's still out on whether or not vice
president Harris is tackling the
challenges with they've deliberated they
went home I'm a diplomat I think the
jury is still out about whether or not
the she's doing and tackling those tasks
that way I think if I were on her team
the only thing I would say to her every
morning at breakfast at lunch at coffee
at tea at dinner whatever people wanted
whatever people do is we've got to get a
border security plan we get a border
security plan all the other things that
we've not done right will go by by
people will forget that and we will not
only help ourselves but help the
president so that'd be my they would be
really benefit from having you at the
White House yes but I'm glad you're here
instead yes and you do more work here so
Greg here's the bottom line issue I mean
she should have known when she sat down
with Lester Holt that she wasn't really
prepared for any questions about the
Border you would think she'd go back and
say you know what that's it I'm gonna
light the candle at both ends and I'm
gonna be on top of that she thought you
did fine that's yeah the cruiser the
Cruisers in life they have such high
self-esteem they never feel bad when
they screw up I envy that I envy being
like Jesse Jesse
you know what I think I did okay but you
know what you know it's like the jury's
still out because the jury left the
courthouse they ran screaming from her
they're not coming back I'm trying to be
a diplomat I know you are you know the
president's claims he's tired of his
number twos number two I think this is a
great strategy for him you don't want a
VP who outshines you that's hard to find
I mean that's easy to find for Joe Biden
so yeah this was tough finding somebody
who doesn't outshine him this was a
Triumph for Biden to find Kamala Harris
she's the least competent person on
Earth I mean you can compare it to like
Mike Pence if something happened to
Trump or he had to resign you could rely
on pants he looks like a vice president
but you know she's like nobody wants
anything to happen to Biden right you
know because then she's in charge but
they to the original Point uh she's a
blueprint example of a terrible hire
made for Noble but naive reasons she's
no different than Sam Brinkman right the
luggage Thief nuclear scientist or
bankman freed you know they're the
fraudster because they're gross
incompetence was cloaked or shielded by
wokeness so that's what you end up with
you had somebody that ticked all the
boxes except qualifications and if you
questioned
God forbid you questions your
qualifications you'd be run over by the
steamroller of big bigoted accusations I
mean she even called her boss a racist
on a debate and they still rewarded her
yeah and then he wonders why they don't
get along okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else